KORY JEFFREY: Greetings,
everyone, and welcome.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the studio is Lisa
Fetterman, the CEO of Nomiku,
who has a hardware and
software solution that
is changing the world
for the food industry.
Tell us a little bit about it.
LISA FETTERMAN: So Nomiku's
the first ever home sous
vide immersion circulator.
And we have a Wi-Fi one
coming out this November
that you can use your app on
your phone for Android or iOS
or Windows Phone, where
it controls your machine.
And you can cook with one tap.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
So for those who don't know, can
you explain what sous vide is?
LISA FETTERMAN: Yes.
Sous vide is a relatively
new thing that's come about,
but it's been used for
decades by top chefs
all around the world.
And now top chefs use my
machine-- [INAUDIBLE].
And what it does is that it
controls water and circulates
it to a very
precise temperature.
What you do is put your
food inside of a bag
and then drop it in
the water, walk away.
When you come back, you
have a world class meal.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
So what's the price point for
something like that, typically?
LISA FETTERMAN: $199.
It used to be
thousands of dollars.
I remember working for
Jean-Georges and Mario Batali.
And we would have this
huge, hulking piece
of laboratory equipment that
was thousands of dollars.
And we would cook a lot
of our components in it.
And I was like, why?
When you took food
out of there, it
was like eating heavenly food.
You know how food
is perfect on TV?
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
LISA FETTERMAN:
It's how they do it.
KORY JEFFREY: Really?
So how long does it take to cook
something using that method?
LISA FETTERMAN: It really ranges
depending on what you cook.
Fish is 20 minutes.
Steak is an hour.
Sometimes short
ribs are 48 hours.
So you put that in there and
then you just go to sleep.
KORY JEFFREY: And
then you wake up
and then you go to sleep again.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So you've recently
had a whole bunch of accolades,
including the White House,
we were talking about.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah.
I'm a White House honored maker.
That's how we got our start
in the Maker Revolution.
We traveled, actually, across
the United States teaching
people how to make
their own DIY,
open source sous vide machines.
Our code is still up on Eagle.
We have our CAD files up.
Whatever people want.
They can make their
own sous vide machine.
That's our start.
And this year, I'm
also Forbes 30 Under 30
and Zagat 30 under 30
for the innovation.
So thank you the media gods.
KORY JEFFREY: It's
a lot of momentum.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah,
This is a way of cooking that
everybody's been waiting for,
myself included.
And I couldn't believe it
hadn't been done before.
It's like modern art.
It's like, oh, you just control
the temperature very precisely?
My kid could do that.
You know what I'm saying?
It was just too obvious, because
ever since the dawn of fire,
we've been trying to control it.
And if you think of our
chefs, what they do,
they're not the controllers
of the ingredients.
That's the farmers.
What they do in the
kitchen is control heat.
And now you can control
heat to 0.1 degrees Celsius.
That's completely revolutionary
to how you can cook.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
And so what's the
market share like?
LISA FETTERMAN:
The market share?
Well, great thing you asked,
because Unilver, Nestle,
and Campbell, they all lose
like $16 billion a year
in market share to people
like me, who cook food the way
that people really, really
want to eat it, like perfectly.
So a big thing that
they lose out on
is frozen food, and
that's packaged food.
And what we do is that we have
packaged food that we sell.
We have it in beta
right now with Bi-Rite.
All you have to do
is go to our website,
and then we ship it
right to your door.
You drop it in the water
and then walk away.
It's just like microwaved food,
except it becomes the freaking
centerpiece of your meal.
KORY JEFFREY: And it doesn't
lose any nutritional value?
LISA FETTERMAN: That's right.
Nothing cooks at above
100 degrees Celsius.
At 57 degrees Celsius,
the fat and the collagen
melt into the muscle of a steak.
Effectively, you can make NY
strip steak taste like Wagyu.
It's so good.
Magic happens.
KORY JEFFREY: You're
making me hungry.
LISA FETTERMAN: Oh good.
OK, you can come eat.
Come eat at Nomiku.
KORY JEFFREY: So you're
also a speaker here today.
You have a booth.
How did the speaking session go?
LISA FETTERMAN: Speaking
session was off the chain.
There's so many people here.
KORY JEFFREY: There are.
There's a lot.
LISA FETTERMAN: So
it was really fun
to speak in front
of a big audience.
KORY JEFFREY: So what
was your message?
What were you trying
to talk about?
LISA FETTERMAN: Message is
the connection between food
and everything in our lives.
People treat food
like, oh, whatever.
They treat it as some
kind of soft thing.
But it's hard.
It's real freaking money.
And also, you put it
in your body every day.
KORY JEFFREY: Captive audience.
LISA FETTERMAN: The experience,
you have to have it.
What's another
experience that you
have with your
body where you put
something inside of your body?
It's a very important thing.
It should be as sacred as that.
KORY JEFFREY: I like that.
That's good.
That's really good.
So what drew you to this event?
LISA FETTERMAN: This
event, I just love
that there's going to
be smart people here.
I don't have to explain
what sous vide is
to every single person.
And also, a lot of cool people,
like Tim Draper was here,
Danielle Fong, Eva
[INAUDIBLE], these people
that I watch from afar
build their stuff.
I'm like, ooh, how you do that?
KORY JEFFREY: That's cool.
LISA FETTERMAN: That's
why it's exciting.
KORY JEFFREY: And
so obviously, you're
a big fan of technology,
food technology.
Is there anything
else in the landscape
that gets you excited from
a technology perspective?
LISA FETTERMAN: From a
technology perspective,
I love all things hardware.
So there's this thing
called Everpurse.
They just partnered
with Kate Spade.
And what they did is that they
made this cute, little bag.
You drop your phone
in and it charges it.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty cool.
LISA FETTERMAN: I need that.
I never charge my phone.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
That's really clever, actually.
LISA FETTERMAN: I love it.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
And do you have a favorite
Google technology?
LISA FETTERMAN: A favorite Goog.
Oh, Goog.
Well, I love Gmail, no doi.
[INAUDIBLE]
You know what I'm saying?
Gmail, I mean, I use it
for my business, too.
It's like lisa@nomiku.com.
That goes through Gmail.
I can't believe I've been
using it for years now.
I probably use a
lot of Google stuff
and I don't even
know it's Google.
KORY JEFFREY: That
is probably true,
which is part of
the point, right?
LISA FETTERMAN: Yes.
Actually, you know what?
One thing that I
really do notice
that I insist on when
I'm in a ride share,
whether it's Lyft
or Uber, I'm like,
can you please use Google Maps?
For god's sake, use Google Maps.
KORY JEFFREY: I
do too, actually.
Well, thank you very
much for joining me.
LISA FETTERMAN: Thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you for joining me.
This has been on site at
Founder World San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]